durante una videollamada durando una
hora el presidente joe biden le dijo el
primer ministro en el render moody que
la posición de la india en el mundo no
mejoraría si dependiera de las fuentes
de energías rusas india ha comprado al
menos 13 millones de barriles de crudo
ruso desde la evasión a finales de
febrero comparado con 16 millones de
barriles durante todo el año pasado
aunque la secretaria de prensa de la
casa blanca james aquí aclaró las
importaciones de energía no están
prohibidas y no violan nuestras
sanciones ciertamente reconocemos que
todos los países van a dar un paso en su
interés en respuesta el ministro de
asuntos exteriores de la india superman
jayson werth declaró el enfoque debe
estar en europa no en la india nuestras
compras totales para el mes serían menos
de lo que europa a comprar una tarde
estos comentarios se hicieron en una
conferencia de prensa conjunta con el
secretario de estado- anthony blinken
blinken agregó que los lazos de india
con rusia se desarrollaron durante
décadas en un momento en que eeuu no
podía ser socio de india pero que los
tiempos habían cambiado desde entonces
con el derrocado primer ministro
pakistaní en brands han alegando una
conspiración extranjera trama de
washington para derrocar su gobierno
preocupaciones indias sobre la
profundización los lazos entre rusia y
china- y la necesidad de modo de
cultivar una imagen desafiante en casa
india está en la situación inusual de no
responder a la presión estadounidense
moody dijo hoy el mundo enfrenta una
situación incierta ya que nadie tiene lo
que quiere la gasolina el petróleo es
fertilizante son difíciles de conseguir
ya que todas las puertas se están
cerrando con el papel crucial que se
espera que desempeña india en la
seguridad alimentaria y de vacunas a
nivel mundial modi también agregó india
está lista para asumir alimentos a mundo
a partir de mañana